[Music]
you
are source
[Music]
abide as source
that which makes awareness
possible
that which makes these endless
creations
hmm
again shout out to amanda rizzo thank
you so much for the
incredible anata i am a strange loop
art music
that very
kaleidoscopic nature
the very fractally
nature of nothingness
and infinity
is what we are and we are
not sensitive enough
to recognize it we have atrophied
our sensitivity via obsession
with maya with our
dreamed creation design being
intoxicated by seeking
peace and happiness externally
and that is the nature of these
realities
what do you identify as are you
the tiny person
or are you the source of it all
as you think so you are
are you the person or are you
source
very very simply put
we're gonna go through
some super
easy
to understand
breakdowns of the nature of reality
and especially spirituality
which is simply realignment
to the one heart
that's all spirituality is is the
realignment
to the one heart you already are
it but you're intoxicated
by your conditioning which is then
creating
ego and distortions
and malevolence and suffering
and spirituality is simply the
realignment
back to know yourself
as the creator know yourself as the
source
that makes awareness and realities
possible
so that's why most spirituality
teaches the very simple analogy
as a first principle which is
that you are not
the clouds that appear and disappear
of thoughts and perceptions and emotions
and beliefs and
objects but rather you're the sky
of awareness in which the clouds appear
and disappear
so you see you're the screen just like
right now
as you're watching this video and the
clouds are like the modulations that
come on the screen
you are the screen awareness is the
screen
and the clouds the modulations appear
and disappear
and when you create this juxtaposition
what you do is you
enable yourself to become more subtle
and more sensitive to what is the very
formless nature of witnessing
of observation of seeing
and then you become aware that that
is god when you stretch out
the awareness beyond the person to the
very impersonal
shared eternal awareness that is what is
meant by god
the very one i the very god
self capital s
and so we became aware of awareness
first and then we became aware that
awareness was shared
impersonal eternal that that is god
and then we become aware that even
awareness itself
or that very nature of god the very
first
attribute of awareness itself
is simulated
you are that which simulates
awareness and then we illusory
create an identity of a sense of
i
to be able to experience
these realities that we create
so you are the source you
are that one infinite intelligence
you are the infinite creator you are
intelligent infinity
you are the very nothingness that gives
rise to the very
infinitude vortexing endlessly
in its witnessing of
infinite transients as these creation
designs
as the very love light lila
the divine plays that they are
so you are the source you are definitely
not the person
so you undergo this process of nettie
nettie not this not that i'm not
the person i'm not
my name i'm not my body i'm not the mind
and it's thoughts and perceptions and
sensations those are just clouds that
appear
in the sky of awareness
so again the screen that gets modulated
just like you're watching right now
and then you become more and more subtly
aware of the very formlessness
of that very i am-ness the very
witnessing the very observer the very
seeing
itself and then you sh
become sensitive to it being impersonal
to it being shared to it being eternal
to
really abiding more and more as that one
god self as the great i am
and then you recognize that even that is
simulated by source even that is the
first attribute of source of emptiness
of void of shunya
so you are that which
makes awareness
you are that which makes realities
identify yourself as that
i am source i am
source i am source
i am source
let's say it three more times together i
am source i
am source and now really feel it with
your eyes closed feel it
i am
source
of awareness of all realities
i am source
i am that which gives rise
to perception
i give rise to perception i
source give rise to perception
i source give rise to awareness
become that which gives rise to
perception
and know yourself as
that
that's when you know your true nature
that is what spirituality
is that is what yoga or union
or mysticism is it means
becoming one with what
with god with the absolute
and you have to become more and more
sensitive
to recognize that god is
that impersonal shared eternal awareness
and that you're not even that but you
are
that which enables awareness you are
that
which makes perception possible you are
that which
makes god possible the great
i am possible
and it's very beautiful because the very
logarithmic
scale of the universe itself when you
put
our solar system in the pupil position
and then you shoot out
past the iris
towards the very outer parts of
that eye at a logarithmic scale you get
this
towards the very
edgeless edge of the universe
the very logarithmic scale
visual of the universe is itself an
eye it's so funny
these are our own hints
to our self i am going to
blatantly hint to myself
that via these illustrations
these very beautiful
clues that i am what makes perception
possible i am what makes
awareness of this universe possible
i gave rise to awareness and to this
universe
for my own exploration
and this is another favorite alex gray's
net of being
again you are the source that gives rise
to
all of these costumes these are all
costumes it is the same sense of eye
behind all of the costumes
now the costumes are unique and they are
beautiful
and they're quote individuated and
that's very beautiful and important
but you can't properly be the firework
of a costume that you are in the world
if you don't know your true nature as
the source because
you will commit malevolence and
suffering
because you don't know your true nature
as that gives
giving rise to everything
so rather than being peace and happiness
which is your true nature
you are trying to extract peace and
happiness from your relationships and
substances and experiences
and that is the archetypal story of the
parable of the prodigal son where the
sledgehammer comes in
and waps you enough times
to where it forces you to turn inward
and investigate the nature of awareness
itself
and that's spirituality that realignment
with the one heart
so it's the same sense of i behind all
these costumes but you are what gives
rise to the sense of i
and even the sense of i is an assumption
this is another way to visualize it
the sense of i is an assumption it is
the crown assumption
it is the crown intoxication
the crown illusion
ask yourself the question repeatedly
what is
i what is
i
i am that which gives birth to the
illusory
sense of i that witnesses
infinite creation
i am that which gives birth to the
illusory sense of
i that witnesses infinite creation
as you think so you are you are not
the person you are that which gives
birth
to the illusory sense of i that
witnesses
infinite creation know yourself
you are source you are the one infinite
creator you are intelligent infinity
you are the absolute
okay
everything is perception you
are its source you are the source of
perception
but the very source itself is
no thing it's unfindable
but it can be known
the very nature of your awareness itself
is not something that you can
pinpoint as an object
rather it is the very formless
subject of the power to know
or observation or witnessing
and then you turn even that into an
object
and you transcend even that
all-inclusive
god awareness because you are that which
makes the perception possible
so you know yourself as the very
unfindable no thing
the very crown assumption is your
hallucination of the sense of self
your very assumption
that there is a sense of self is the
biggest
intoxicative hallucination
i am constantly [ __ ] slapping myself
into alignment
i use this entire reality to [ __ ] slap
all of these costumes repeatedly into
alignment
with know thyself as
the creator as source as intelligent
infinity endlessly expressing itself
consciousness is the background and
needs to see
itself then transcend itself you have to
know the
very screen itself
the screen that experiences the
modulations
just like the sky that experiences the
clouds
arising and disappearing
so you need to know yourself as that
very background awareness consciousness
witnessing observation
and really see yourself as that first
and then expand it outward to include
all inclusive awareness the very great i
am that won god's self and transcend
even that to become the source of what
makes perception and witnessing possible
it's already one intelligence with no
sense of i we're just not
sensitive enough to detect it
it's pretty simple you've become
identified with yourself
as a person and so you've lost all of
your sensitivity to detect that
awareness is formless and i am that
which
makes the first attribute of awareness
itself
that then has this very illusory
appearance
of having a sense of self and a sense of
i that then contracts even
further into becoming identified with a
name
and a body and a career and
relationships
and all of your social media accounts
and needing to prove yourself
right online you see
how all of that creates suffering and
malevolence
because you don't know your true nature
as the very
bliss and peace and as that which
creates
the very nature of the bliss peace
witnessing
of infinite creation
so you literally think that other people
are these separate entities
and you're in some sort of physical
world
rather than knowing that you are the
source of the first attribute of
awareness which is formless and residing
as at least
that first attribute of awareness rather
than residing as a physical creature in
a physical world with a bunch of
separate physical creatures
this is all one vortex of the very void
to infinitude
endlessly undergoing a lila
a divine play but you don't know that
and so because of that you create
malevolence and suffering
so become sensitive enough to detect
your true nature it's constantly there
but you've become insensitive to it
there's been an atrophying of you
knowing yourself as
source most simply put you've atrophied
your true nature
as source now you think you're a person
a very contracted form of identity
that is the very nature of reality is
the fact that
you are deluded into your contraction
of identity rather than knowing yourself
as the source
of awareness and the source of these
realities
so everything becomes super trippy
because
you spend your whole life with this
illusory sense of i and then it
dissolves
my very 28 years of life
had this sense of i the entire time
and there was this constant
nature of the sense of i in being a
separate
physical entity on a rock with a bunch
of separate physical entities
and it's just spirituality is realigning
to your true nature to that one heart
and pop
it's so beautiful it's a big pup
yourself back two times pop
once from the person into
awareness and then pop the second time
from awareness
pop to the absolute that which makes
awareness to the
source of awareness the source of
perception itself
and then you as a jedi can navigate all
these layers all these lenses without
a problem and help others be in pure
service to them
because now you know your true nature
so you go where self and no self meet
the very nature of avoiding void
is where self and no self meet
they are inextricable they are best
friends they are like
glue and that's exactly where the
illusion
happens of self is right there
at that very last attribute to transcend
awareness towards the very nothingness
of source of the absolute
so self is the crown assumption
and when you recognize that self
is the crown assumption this catalyzes
emptiness because
you become more and more aware of how
your sense of eye
you've indoctrinated and diluted
yourself into and so you become more and
more empty as the very source is the
very absolute
and then that dissolves the conditioning
you're no longer all of this baggage
of your onion layers of identity
all these distortions and delusions and
contractions
and so even those slowly dissolve all of
that conditioning
and then that's what enables you to
firework most
optimally in pure love light
service to others from roots that are
pure
because you know yourself as source you
have become source
full
this very emptiness enables rikpa the
very ground
knowledge of the ground of your true
nature
so you've become a gnostic
being because you know yourself as the
very source
of awareness and reality
versus being the bs layers of identity
that then are part of that conditioning
which then as you firework creates
suffering and malevolence because you
don't know your true nature
so be free of identity attachments
conditioning psychology
point of view ideas and in doing so
this enables you to be hyper successful
in pure service to others
shepherding the ignition of the global
awakening
shepherding the planetary enlightenment
that we
also desperately seek it starts
within it starts with your identity are
you a person
are you awareness are you the absolute
are you the source of
awareness and of reality and do you see
how it's
all one intelligence at play and how
there is
no sense of i do you see
that because if you see that if you know
that
you can't commit malevolence you can't
commit suffering
because you become the maximal shepherd
you no longer come from your
conditioning but you come from
source boom
so we invent the self
that in itself is such a profound
revelation that we invent
the idea that there is a self
it's such a sticky intoxicative
hallucination
so we invent the very importance of us
to use this first
attribute to be able to witness and
observe our infinite creation
so emptiness invents the self it just is
and we call itself this is the very
one intelligence of void to infinity
endlessly
vortexing and we add
this very cheeky [ __ ] source
that makes it so that we
are i rather than us being the source of
i so it's the very cheeky [ __ ]
illusory hallucination itself
that we create in order for us to be
able to
observe and experience to witness
to be aware to have the power to know
28 years self-inventing the lie
of i it's a very powerful statement
how many dozens of years have you
self-invented
the lie of i and how can you
blast past that to knowing your true
nature
as that very anata as that very no
self as that very one intelligence void
to infinity endlessly vortexing
the very stillness and the very endless
movement transcend
go beyond coming and going go beyond
birth and death go beyond the
unmanifested and the manifested
keep going beyond beyond beyond beyond
and what you get to
is you get to ineffable perfection and
that's it
we have to illusory intoxicate ourselves
with i
for individual to experience reality
they need
this sense of i so no self and illusory
self have to be
married as [ __ ] for there to be a power
to know slash
i am
that very nature of no self self
is so inextricable such a hallucinated
illusion
because we need it for the very power to
know
again it's the very crown assumption is
this very
self capital s the one god
self we as
intelligent infinity are genius for
making the sticky illusory sense of
i we as the one infinite creator are
genius
a void void simulates the sense of
i your very nature as source
simulates the sense of i in order for it
to be able to witness
infinite creation it's unbelievably
genius we are that
which is genius as
source designing the nature of the
illusory intoxicative eye
to infinitely witness creation
transcend even perception god
what you simulate to know so transcend
even what you simulate as the attribute
of perception of god to be able to know
these creations
so our most illusory first principle
is our most needed so the very nature of
the first
attribute itself that is so illusory and
intoxicative is our most needed
it's the most mission critical it's the
most paramount
we have to have the power to know we
have to have awareness
so we as source slash creates or have to
use perpetual sticky first attribute to
experience
realities we as source creator
use this very perpetually sticky first
attribute
to experience realities to witness to
observe this infinite creation
we use this very illusory intoxicative
sense of
i and so
that's why we're so passionate about
a navigable roadmap for awakening
because there are these very pop moments
as we described throughout the show is
as you think so you are you think you're
a person
but awakening is realignment to the one
intelligence
so you pop from being a person to being
awareness which is a big step
but then people think it ends there it
doesn't end there you pop
from being a awareness to recognizing
infinity you recognize the very nature
of the one god self
being the infinite observer or the
infinite witness
and then you recognize the very source
void emptiness
shunya absolute that
is the unmanifested that manifests the
first
attribute itself of awareness that
enables you to have the power to know so
there are these
pops that happen for you
and that this very last pop from the
sense of self
to the sense of no self from the very
ottman to the anatman to the very anata
the very no
self is mission critical for you to know
this is one massive your nature
as source creating this one mass of
decentralized
swarm intelligence god's love light
leela that
plays endlessly in its creations
and so we need this navigable road map
it's mission critical so much of the
planet is still
stuck in this third density matrixy
governments and politicians and economic
machinery and media propaganda
and fast food high fructose corn syrup
all these nonsensical
indoctrinated belief structures and they
have absolutely no will and no choice
and no self-awareness and no sovereignty
but you have to recognize that you are
that
i am that i am all of those costumes
and for me to create the architectures
that enable these costumes to awaken is
the coolest thing that i could possibly
do boom
so that's the nature you are source
all right that's all adore you so much
thank you for tuning in would love for
you to like the video for brought you
value helps the algorithm subscribe if
you haven't yet to the channel
leave a comment below with your thoughts
about being source
share the video with other people that
you know this would resonate with
you our source
and we'll
outro with some music as well
again thanks amanda rousseau
again it's anata i am a strange loop and
you can
find it on the link
in the bio below is down there go and
check it out
just tap in to the very
knowledge i am source
i am source i
am source i am not my person identity
i am at least awareness even more
i am the source of awareness
i am source i am source i am
[Music]
source
[Music]
[Music]
all right that's it i am
source abide spirituality
is the realignment to knowing yourself
as source as the one infinite creator
thank you